in previous videos we've already talked
about the idea that there are times in
Earth's orbit when it is closer to the
Sun and when it is further from the Sun
and when it is closer to the Sun so
let's say that this is the time of the
orbit when it's closer to the Sun this
is the perihelion perihelion perihelion
and when it is farthest from the Sun and
I'm exaggerating the difference
this is aphelion this is the aphelion in
our orbit when we are close when we are
furthest from the Sun it may be our
orbit may be our orbit looks something
like this
so maybe our orbit looks something it
shouldn't have that bulge over there so
maybe our orbit looks something like
this over here and what I point out in
the first video where we discussed this
is that this is not the cause of the
seasons even though we are three percent
closer right now where the way our orbit
is set up and we'll see in future videos
that this that the difference or the the
eccentricity or how how elliptical the
orbit is does change over time how much
it deviates from being circular that's
how you can that's one way to think
about eccentricity that does change over
time but right now when we are closest
to the Sun we are 3% closer than when we
are furthest from the Sun so 3% closer
than at aphelion and we point out in the
first video and rediscover tick Euler in
particular perihelion when we are
closest to the Sun when we actually have
the most radiation from the Sun that's
actually when we have the northern
hemisphere when we have the Northern
Hemisphere winter so this occurs right
over here this occurs in January
this occurs in January and aphelion
occurs in July occurs in July now based
on this this might lead to an
interesting question because so let's
think about January let's think about
January when we are at perihelion and
let's think about July let's think about
July we're going to aphelion and let me
draw a quick globe right over here and
let's make that the equator and I'll
draw it in both situations in both
situations so January is
obviously when we have the Northern
Hemisphere winter so I'll call paint it
in blue right over here it is winter
winter and July is when we have the
Northern Hemisphere summer or the
southern hemisphere winter so then we
have winter winter during July in the
southern hemisphere and let me put
summer in a in a more summery color I
guess that orange is a pretty good color
that's not Orange
here's orange all right
that's orange and that's orange so these
are summer summer so that's the summer
in the southern hemisphere which occurs
during the winter in the Northern
Hemisphere and vice versa
summer in the Northern Hemisphere occurs
during winter in the southern hemisphere
and so the question might be rising in
your head and I did see a few comments
on that first video asking this question
and it's a good one if we are closer if
we are closer to the Sun in January or
we are clearly closest to the Sun in
January this is the perihelion right
over here and so we're getting more
solar radiation in January
does that moderate the winter does that
moderate the winter so does that
moderate the winter in the Northern
Hemisphere or I guess another way to
think about it does it make the wind
does it make the summer in the southern
hemisphere when we are closer to the Sun
does it make it more extreme does it
make it more extreme or hotter and vice
versa in July when we are when we are
furthest from the Sun does that moderate
the Northern Hemisphere winter because
it's hot up there but hey we're a little
bit further from the Sun and does it
make the southern hemisphere winter
colder so once again does it make this
more extreme because it's already winter
and we're further from the Sun so maybe
we're also getting less radiation and so
there's a couple of ways to think about
it one it is true that when we're
further we are getting a little bit less
radiation from the Sun or we're getting
heated up a little bit less but the one
reality is that the southern hemisphere
climate as a whole is not more extreme
despite getting heated up getting more
solar energy in the summer and getting
less solar
energy in the winter and the reason why
it is not an extreme let me draw the
equator here just so that we can
separate our hemispheres
the main reason it is believed wet it is
not more extreme is that the southern
hemisphere has a lot more water in it so
just if you look at the surface of the
southern hemisphere you're looking at a
lot more water than the surface of the
northern hemisphere this is of course as
a Mercator projection and so it distorts
things so that things near the poles get
really kind of built up to look really
huge even though they really aren't that
big Greenland really isn't the larger
than South America it just spreads them
out so that you can kind of but you
don't have to have so you can flatten
out the map so to speak but the southern
hemisphere has more water and as you may
have learned in chemistry class water
has a higher specific heat higher
specific energy it takes a higher
specific energy it takes more energy
more heat to raise water a degree than
it does to take to raise se to raise
land of a degree and so water can absorb
more energy or when there's less energy
water will release more energy without
dropping as much of a temperature so
water has a moderating influence water
has a moderating influence on the
climate so I even though the summers in
the southern hemisphere actually are
getting more radiation than the summers
in the northern hemisphere
it's moderated on the actual temperature
because the water has the ability to
absorb more of that heat without
changing the temperature as dramatically
now with that said it is true that in
general Antarctica is colder Antarctica
is colder is colder than the North Pole
but the main reason why Antarctica is
colder besides the fact that it's on
land as opposed to Antarctica being they
are as opposed to the North Pole being
in the center of the Arctic Ocean is
that it's actually a huge very high
altitude ice sheet and so the altitude
for most of Antarctica is around 8,000
feet so it's kind of like an Alpine
added altitude so the main reason why
it's colder is it may be you know
possibly being further away from the Sun
and winter might play some role there
but the main reason why it's colder is
it is it's just at a much higher
altitude and it's to some degree
insulated from the water or I guess you
could say it's on the land so especially
during the long winters it's going to
get that much colder but I'll leave you
there and
and to some degree and this is the other
aspect of it during the summers the D
and you know all of this stuff is super
complicated so you can't you know you
can't just throw it one rule of thumb
and say this is the reason but these are
all influences is that if you have a
large super large icy sheet it's also
more likely to reflect more of the
energy because it's white as opposed to
a darker color like the ocean or the
land and so you could think about all of
those factors but the general answer is
it's a good question
but overall the climate in the southern
hemisphere is not more extreme than the
climate in the southern hemisphere
even though Antarctica is colder